una de las mayores filtraciones de
documentos financieros de la historia es
cuando ahora papers revelan como 35
líderes mundiales 300 funcionarios
públicos congregaciones religiosas
artistas y multimillonarios operaron a
través de offshores y fideicomisos en
paraísos fiscales como panamá dubai
mónaco las islas vírgenes británicas o
el estado de dakota del sur en eeuu para
no pagar impuestos ocultar y blanquear
dinero en este caso aunque tener una
jurisdicción offshore no en un paraíso
fiscal técnicamente no es un delito el
alto nivel de secretismo y las
atractivas ventajas tributarias de estos
territorios han permitido que algunos
clientes puedan evadir impuestos en sus
en sus países puedan lavar dinero o
puedan esconder lo de ahí que o sea de
gran alerta que muchos mandatarios en
especial en américa latina' aparezcan en
estos registros en américa latina la
región más desigual del mundo 14 líderes
políticos entre ellos 3 presidentes de
corte conservador actualmente en el
cargo aparecen en las investigaciones el
chileno sebastián piñera el ecuatoriano
guillermo lasso y el dominicano luis
abinader en el caso de piñera hizo
negocio offshore en las islas vírgenes
británicas relacionados con la minera
dominga el ex banquero lazo llegó a
operar 14 sociedades inscritas en
paraísos fiscales está haciéndose de
ellas antes de presentarse a las
elecciones por su parte el político y
empresario abinader aparece vinculado a
dos sociedades secretas en panamá entre
los onces mandatarios hay dos
colombianos césar gaviria y andrés
pastrana el peruano pedro pablo
kuczynski o el paraguayo horacio cardio